our goal is pretty simple I want to help
you get what's in here and just splash
it onto there don't worry it's not
rocket science
harder
thanks for going to a special place with
me
Carl
got it that tree is probably too tall
brace yourself you are going to get some
calls about that
[Music]
Mr nargle it is an honor to meet you sir
wait what's going on
[Music]
paint to a whole new place and it's been
a lot of places good night everyone
I've never seen him that mad
[Music]
don't let Fame bring out the horse in
you real man never looks back he's the
new tote bags it's only because yours
weren't selling you're lucky I'm an
artist instead of a woman who says
really mean things to other women you
were an artist
[Music]
the real artist follows his heart my
Uber is here I don't know what that is
it's goodbye
[Music]
how's everything going awesome
what's the image tucked away in your
brain that makes your heart ache and
your soul feel like it's going to burst
[Music]
Carl is one-dimensional and very sexist
you know I don't care what people say
about me
[Music]
oh
PBS Burlington
yes we're aware that Carl is stealing
newspapers please hold